it is my great pleasure to introduce dr.
professor Ramirez this morning now most
of you probably know professor Ramirez
because she hosts science Saturday's
what you may or may not know is that
Professor Ramirez imagined invented and
created this program and a huge amount
of blood sweat and tears went into
actually making this happen so for all
those of you who enjoy it we should
start by giving professor now besides
being extraordinary and creating and
running this program and making it
happen every term professor Ramirez is
probably one of the best scientists that
I have ever had the privilege of knowing
and a really fantastic researcher she is
going to be talking a little bit today
about some of the research she does so
I'll let her take care of that but one
of the things she may not talk about is
that she's also a phenomenal teacher she
has one of the most popular classes in
engineering and she's in fact
essentially recreating a field in
engineering because everyone wants to
keep taking material science after they
go to professor in mirrors his class so
she's a fantastic teacher an amazing
scientist and we'll get to see a little
window on that today besides all of that
she's also one of the great mentors here
at Yale she really looks after everyone
and she's a phenomenal friend and we're
very very lucky to have her so with that
thank you very much what a green inches
i'm done well today i have the
opportunity to sit on the other side of
the podium and talk to you a little bit
about some of the research that I'm
doing so my talk is entitled metals with
memories and other smart materials I
think the best way to get started is
actually to show you this at work so let
me just get some hot water here if you
can look at the books are just going to
take a little bit of adjusting look at
the side things alright so we have some
hot water and what I'm going to do is
I'm just going to show you this this
wire which you may be familiar with
already this wire right here can you see
that okay now all I'm going to do is
wrap it around my finger so there's no
magic you can see it happening in real
time and I'm going to slip it into the
water alright so I'm done with my talk
thank you very much alright so what I'm
going to do today is I'm going to talk a
little bit about why this material does
what it does all right why does this
material remember now what did we see we
saw the wire I bent it i heated it with
hot water and went back straight so
today we'll talk a little bit about the
mechanism behind what's going on what
are the atoms doing now before we get
started this material does have a name
it has an official name it's called
nitinol it's not the most creative name
but it actually tells us quite a bit
about the material the first part of the
name niti it tells us that the material
is made out of nickel and titanium 50-50
equal amount the second part nawl that
tells us where it was made in a small
laboratory in maryland all right so
there are many names that this material
also has besides nitinol and I'll kind
of use them interchangeably but you may
hear me say shape memory alloys memory
metal you'll also see muscle wire or
SMAS which is just an acronym to say
shape memory alloys so this is the
material that will be talking about
today why shape memory alloys do what
they do what you just saw I'm over to go
now before we get started and talking
about how they
change their shape we have to talk about
atoms no no not Adam atoms this is what
I mean at all right so Adams we all kind
of have an idea what atoms are about
they have a positive core with the
neutrons and the protons circulating
around them are the electrons well we
don't need to go into that much detail
into understanding why materials do what
they do we can actually step back and
look at materials more from billiard
balls from hard spheres right and so
billiard balls or oranges they all kind
of have this circular shape and they
also have some kind of organization they
kind of order themselves in certain ways
well Adams as well order themselves and
we'll talk about that in just a moment
there's a few ways that Adams can order
themselves there's actually 14 of them
they're called bravais lattices can you
say that bra Bay lattices rob a lattices
exactly see if when you find something
you can name it after yourself all right
and so the thing is that where the
material that we're interested in uses
two unique structures cubic which looks
like this just a cube all sides the same
all angles or 90 degrees and also
monoclinic which looks like this you
know pass it around if you want to look
all right just so you can see I always
describe monoclinic to look more like an
a pink eraser that kind of shifted shape
right and what happens is that at higher
temperatures atoms like to be a
nickel-titanium light to be arranged in
this cubic arrangement and at lower
temperatures they like to be in this
monoclinic arrangement now these
different arrangements also have names
because once again when you find
something you can name it after yourself
so high temperatures that's austenite
low temperatures that's martensite all
right so when we just saw a moment ago
this wire that was bent and that when we
heated it it became straight what we
were seeing on a macroscopic level is
what atoms are doing on a very very
microscopic level that is they're
changing for martensite when we heat it
to austenite all right so Adams these
very small entities 10 to the minus 10
that is if i were to your hair is about
100 microns if
I were to sit on a stoop and Whittle a
piece of hair 10,000 times one of those
shavings would be the thickness of an
atom so it's that scale that's impacting
the material that you're seeing in
creating forming our austenite well how
are these atoms doing this well there's
essentially a parade have you ever seen
a really great parade but those really
sophisticated ones where they're
starting to move in different ways maybe
they have some really great music
playing that's what the atoms are doing
they're shifting around and they're
creating a new phase a new structure
here's a way to kind of just see that
another way we're seeing that these
atoms are shifting from a martensite to
now austenite martensite back to
austenite and all they're doing is
they're just doing this by a simple
shift to different materials but just by
a simple shift and that's what's so
great about these materials well I think
I want to really get this message home
so why don't we try this out this
computer is a very smart computer has a
mind of its own actually and what we're
going to do is it's going to flash red
and it's going to flash blue to indicate
that we're cooling or that we're heating
right and when we're cooling we're
forming martensite so we'll all put our
hands this way all right to the side and
when we're heating we're forming
austenite which is a cubic straight
structure and so we'll put our hands
this way very good all right so let's
see what the first one is all right this
way brilliant this way this way oh it's
the wave great fantastic all right so
you see this process of going back and
forth great great boy we're on fire
alright so this the small shift is what
the atoms are doing now I mentioned this
word phase a couple of times to describe
austenite martensite and I think I
should be a little bit more clear about
those things so what is a phase well
there's a couple of definitions I kind
of did a survey one it's it's something
that you're going through something that
annoys your parents and lastly it's a
distinct form of matter and we're
familiar with a few of them if we have
states of matter such as water we know
that it equal it exists as gas right
vapor link
would right and what's the solid form
again ice exactly so those are different
those are different phases of water of
the same thing here's an example of two
phases existing at the same time I have
a beaker where I'm heating water and I
have two phases present at the same time
the liquid and the vapor so we can have
two different phases based on state but
we can also have materials that are the
same state like a solid but there are
different phases as well and we can see
that we see that fairly commonly carbon
can have two different phases it
actually has a way to describe carbon
having two different phases is also
allotrope can you say allotrope
allotrope that means it has different
phases now we can have carbon in the
graphite phase you can see a picture of
it located right there we can also have
carbon in the diamond phase very
different properties right do you want a
pencil made out of diamond yes you do
because you want to you want to sell
that that's right but you don't want to
use it that's right so but we have
graphite which is a very soft material
and we have diamond which is the hardest
material that we know they're both made
out of carbon but the difference is that
they just have different atomic
structures so different arrangements can
give rise to different phases and that's
what the nickel titanium is doing it's
creating different phases but it's just
do this doing this by a displace of
motion moving from one arrangement to
another now why do I keep saying this
why does Professor Ramirez keep talking
about this displaced moment well it's
because most materials don't do this
that is create different phases just by
shifting their position most undergo
diffusion now if I were to go down the
middle of this row here and everyone on
this side is an A Adam pee out that's
right brilliant all right over here B
atoms be hey hey how's it going all
right so let's say that I wanted to
create a new compound a be right so the
eight items are here the B atoms are
here and I want a and B to come together
now these lucky people right here it's
very easy for them to make a compound
because they can move very short
distances however my friend over here
has to travel a significant distance to
get over to the B side right and that
takes time that takes also a significant
amount of temperature because we have to
give them enough energy to do that
that's not the case for shape memory
alloys they just
make a small shift and they're already a
very big they're already a different
phase so that's why I keep emphasizing
this the other thing is that only a few
compounds do this it's based on some
geometrical constraints based on these
different structures so only a handful
of materials do this and lastly this
mechanism this transformation which has
an official name the martensitic
transformation is still a mystery in a
lot of ways and that's good because that
provides job security for me so we can
think of these materials as transducers
because what we're doing is we're
applying heat and we're getting force so
it's changing its changing energy it's
changing it from heat to force so that's
what we'll think about these materials
now there are many uses for this
material not only because of the fact
that it goes through this phase change
but also because it's flexible so some
of them some of you may be going through
the stage right now where you have
authored on tech space and it may have
some shape memory alloys you'll also see
that these materials are quite a handy
and some eyewear in fact i have an
example of one right here so look at the
camera on the side look at this
wonderful first aren't these lovely all
right all right so here's my here's my
glasses would you do this to your
parents class no you wouldn't do that
you would get in trouble what's also
nice about these materials is if I cool
them down so this is just liquid
nitrogen which we love right no no okay
so here's liquid nitrogen really cold
stuff all right liquid nitrogen is one
of my favorite things all right so here
I am I'm going to put this into the
liquid nitrogen oh this is great this is
awesome I look at that it's stuck and
here's a spring it's also made out of
the shape memory wire which you can see
right and it's actually kind of hard to
pull well I'll put this in the liquid
nitrogen as well do that right here and
boy is it flexible now
extremely flexible so I'll let you look
at that and as it warms up as it warms
up you'll see that it'll go back to its
original shape all right so very
flexible you can see it see it at work
there so so here's some uses not only
before the phase change but also because
it's highly flexible what other uses are
out there well it's also instance if you
have a blocked artery they put in a
spring of this material and it will open
up any kind of closure there's also some
toys that are based on this and also
some robotic structures in fact there's
a butterfly that's been moving right
here it's based on the shape memory
alloy and lastly most embarrassingly
underwire bras all right so you can
imagine after you've deformed it from
use you can pop it in the dryer it goes
back into shape so now we know what
victoria's secret is huh she's a
metallurgist all right so let's get a
little bit more technical about what's
going on with these materials once again
we saw that there's a phase change as we
heat it from low temperature too high
temperature and it's changing from
martensite to austenite now we can
visualize this change because we see the
wire changing shape but we also know
that properties change as well and one
property being the resistivity its
ability to conduct electricity also the
stress and the material these are things
that also change as we go along as we
increase the temperature and this curve
represents that see if we start at low
temperatures here we heat and we start
to form austenite as this dot AF
indicates that's the start of austenite
as we increase we finish and we have the
end point of austenite the austenite
finish point and then if we start to
cool we start to form martensite and
then we continue until we finish forming
martensite and this this curve is called
a hysteresis curve it means that you
don't go back the way he started we all
have hysteresis I don't know about you
but when I go to work I travel one way
and when I come back home I travel
another way hysteresis well these
materials do the same thing and as an
engineer we want to tailor the
properties and one that property we're
particularly interested in is the height
of this thing how can we increase the
height because that will speed
to how much force can be created we want
to have more force and we want to be
able to tailor how we create this force
so we'll talk about how we do that in
just a moment now I've talked about
cheap memory alloys and they seem to be
somewhat of a mature technology but what
I'm interested in is looking at these on
a very small scale these are small
devices this is a MEMS device micro
electromechanical systems amends device
it's a mirror and it's very small the
width of this mirror if i look at this
goal piece right here that's 250 microns
across your hair is 60 microns alright
just to give you a sense of scale this
is the eye of a needle and you can see
them now these mirrors need to be tilted
because you're going to move light and
we need to figure out ways or ways to
move these materials in one material one
potential material could be shape memory
alloys so how do we make shape memory
alloys that are very small so that
they'll be used to be useful for these
very small devices that's the question
that I'm interested in so how do we make
very small layers for these devices well
my pocket knife is not that sharp to
shave off a little bit to get to 250
microns so we actually use another
process it's called sputtering once
again think of the atoms is billiard
balls so if i have a billiard balls of
nickel and titanium if i have an atom
that I'm that is inert meaning it won't
form a compound with this material and I
shoot it in the direction of the nickel
titanium what will happen well think of
it as a cue ball hitting all the other
call colored balls in billiards they
will all cascade and because of this
momentum transfer will create a raining
if you will of these different atoms now
if we have a plate to collect these
atoms which we officially call the
substrate they'll slowly deposit onto
this material right and afterwards since
the atoms are not any specific
arrangement meaning that they're not in
the cubic formation or in the monoclinic
formation they're not in austenite or
they're not in martensite we actually
have to put them in the oven to make
sure that they do this so this is
scientific cooking and here's an analogy
just to kind of show you that so
everybody familiar with the notion of
cake
cake is very very good all right well
how do what do we have to think about
when we make a cake well we have to
worry about the ingredients the amount
of the ingredients the oven temperature
and the time what happens if you put a
cake in there for too long what happens
burns right so these are all the things
that we have to worry about well once we
do that if we have all the ingredients
we have to make me worry about the
texture which will tell us is this a dry
cake is it a runny cake these are the
things that we worry about and lastly
the most important thing we're
interested in is its property whether
it's yummy or not right well we can make
a parallel for one of the processes for
how we develop materials and that is as
such where we have processing that is
how we synthesize it how that relates to
the structure it could be the structure
of the atoms or collections of atoms
that form grains or crystals and lastly
how that relates to property whatever
property you're interested in well
essentially I guess I'm a chef in some
ways because I look at nickel-titanium
films that are very thin I put them into
a furnace and I anneal them that process
of heating up these materials is called
annealing I look at the micro structure
that is the collection of atoms and see
how those structures look look and see
how they're related to the actuation
properties that is its ability to move
so that's what essentially what I'm
doing so let's look at this process of
atoms collecting and forming grains in
real time so you can see in this very
gray area we essentially have an
amorphous material meaning we don't have
materials we don't have atoms in any
kind of arrangement but you're starting
to see these white dots those are small
grains inside of them are atoms that
have a periodic arrangement sort of like
that marching a band again but they're
in a structure of austenite and we
continue to heat this material until all
of that area is covered with these these
grains until it's fully crystallized
alright we're still banking well still
baking thing time's up alright so this
is baked and so the experiment that I'm
interested in doing is looking at how we
can heat these materials up at different
temperatures and what's the final
structure look like
well let's look at that those kinds of
images here is an example of films that
have been heated to different
temperatures and they have different
grain size the temperatures are
indicated at the bottom 510 degrees
that's our high temperature case four
hundred and sixty-five degrees which is
our low temperature case if you don't
recall which C is and how that relates
to Fahrenheit just multiply these
numbers by two and add 30 that's an
approximate for how hot it is these are
fairly high temperatures now what's
interesting is that at lower
temperatures we have very large grains
you see this big rain right here you see
that that's a grain and over here we
have smaller grains do you see that now
what's interesting is that these grains
have lines in them those lines indicate
martensite remember that monoclinic
structure that's kind of floating around
the one that kind of looked shifted that
indicates martensite right there so
these big rains have quite a bit of
martensite however these smaller grains
at the lower temperature they don't seem
to have as much martensite so we see
already that there's a significant
difference in the way that you cook
these materials are the way you anneal
these materials you get very different
microstructures at low temperatures you
have big grains and they have quite a
bit martensite at high temperatures you
have smaller grains and not as much
martensite so in terms of that process
relating the process to the
microstructure we've gotten that part
done the last part is to relate this to
properties well here's those curves
those hysteresis curves that I talked
about a moment ago and we're looking at
those examples that I showed just
moments ago where we have the high
temperature case and the low temperature
case you can see that the hysteresis or
the height of these curves is
significantly different we have a low
hysteresis curve and we have a high
hysteresis curve at lower temperatures
so once again the the object of the game
is to create materials that have higher
hysteresis curves and what we can learn
here is that lower temperatures are the
way to go in order to create devices
that will have larger forces that make
sense all right so what we're doing is
we're cooking and we're relating it to
the properties and that's pretty much
material science is all about now i want
to change gears if you and i would like
to also talk about another material
that's a smart material that might be of
interest to you its base it's a
piezo-electric material it's based on
piezo electricity piezo electricity
comes from the term of the greek term
for a PA tzin which means to press or to
squeeze and electricity well that means
don't touch alright and this is a
transducer as well it has properties of
relating pressure to electricity doesn't
that sound strange I apply pressure and
I get electricity that's what these
materials do I'll give you an example of
this at work here i have a small disk
made out of piezo-electric material and
attached to it is a small LED that
picture shows it right there and what
I'm going to do is I'm just going to
apply impact or pressure and this will
this should envision this should light
up so here's me at work here's my little
video we're all i'm doing is hitting
this surface now do you see it do you
see it now you don't see it it's too
dark so what we'll do is well dim the
lights a little bit and try it again
do you see it all right so all i did was
apply pressure and i was able to get
this this spark right i'm not a battery
although the matrix says i'm a battery
i'm not a battery but i was able to get
this spark and so that's what this
material is doing that's this
piezo-electric material now what's the
mechanism the mechanism is such once
again think of those atoms think of
these atoms having an arrangement but
not only do they have an arrangement
they also have a charge so those are
indicated there's pluses and minuses
there now when I apply a force or
pressure what do i do I change the
structure I change the structure so that
on one side we have more positives on
the other side I have more negatives can
you see that and that's what creates
this charge so that's what these
materials do when I apply an impact I
change the structure the structure has
some charge to it and so that's why I'm
able to see these this spark that you
saw just a moment ago and there's some
piezoelectric materials that out there
one of them is quartz that's actually
most popular but I've recently found out
that our bone has some piezo-electric
now that's not why you feel energetic
but it's on a very small scale also
sugarcane has some piezo electric
properties as well so just to give you a
sense of some things are out there but
quartz is actually probably the most
dominant or the most popular where r
piezo-electric materials where where
they applied well they're often in
loudspeakers you know you apply
electricity to these materials they move
and they cause sound waves right they're
also used in lighters I have an example
of wanting right here right that
clicking noise that you hear you're
hitting a piece of quartz you're hitting
a piece of quartz to create a spark and
there's fuel here which will start set
the flame so this is this is
piezo-electric materials at work now
scientists also do some future thinking
about what to do with piezo electric and
its proposed that we can use ourselves
to create energy now how do we do that
well every time we walk we waste energy
all that energy just kind of goes into
the floor imagine if at the bottom of
your shoe you had a piezo-electric
material and that you're able to store
this material and into some kind of
battery then you'd be able to charge up
your your mp3 player or your cell phone
or the like so this is kind
futuristic this is called energy
harvesting but researchers are actually
working on this because there's
materials that will do this so this is
some kind of future thinking as well and
this is what scientists do as well they
see a material and then they look for a
kind of far out application so maybe in
a couple of years we'll have such shoes
well we spent a little bit of time
together thinking about materials we've
noticed that what's important is that
the atomic arrangements can give rise to
different kinds of structures and
different kinds of properties we saw
that when we apply heat we can get phase
transformations and also when we apply
pressure we can also get electricity so
I hope that you found this fruitful and
I'll take any questions if there's any
opportunity